good morning and good afternoon everyone
and welcome to today's webinar our topic
today is a virtual workshop for precise
HDR mediated genome engineering with
CRISPR cast nine my name is Louise
Baskin I'm a Senior Product Manager here
at Dharma Khan and I will be the
moderator for today's broadcast for
anyone who is not familiar with us
Dharma Khan has been supporting the RNA
and gene modulation research community
for over 20 years we launched the very
first synthetic CRISPR cast nine guide
RNAs and we now offer one of the most
comprehensive CRISPR gene editing
portfolios in the industry including the
first arrays synthetic crispr RNA whole
human genome library we remain focused
on the development and support of
innovative effective tools for the
greater research community for today's
webinar you can submit questions anytime
during the event by typing them into the
Q&A box you just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of a
presentation window we do have
scientists standing by to answer your
questions in real-time so you might also
see a response in this window some
questions will be held until the end for
the live Q&A session with our presenter
any questions that don't get answered
during the event will receive an email
response from one of our technical
support scientists if you want to
maximize your view the presentation
window can be enlarged by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner and if you experience any
technical problems with the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right or submit the problems
through that green Q&A button this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
C e button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credit and I'd now like to introduce
today's speaker Marin mayor growth Marin
is a scientist in the Rd group she
received her degree in biochemistry and
molecular biology at the College of
Wooster in 2004 and she joined Dharma
Khan in 2005 she's contributed to
research projects and the development of
new products in multiple areas
across RNA interference as well as Chris
Burke s9 genome engineering and today
she's going to take you through some
virtual HDR experiments to provide some
very practical advice on how to be
successful with these applications and
I'll now turn it over to Marian for the
presentation hello thank you for joining
us today and louise thank you for the
introduction today I will walk us
through all the steps that we need to
consider when planning HDR mediated gene
editing experiments with CRISPR casts
nine our goal here is to show you how we
at Dyea makaan have many resources and
tools available to make these complex
experiments easy to plan and design as a
scientist myself this has made my life a
lot easier and I hope this is helpful
for you two for the agenda today I will
give a brief crisper cast 9 refresher to
make sure that we're all on the same
page then introduce some CRISPR cast
line applications utilizing the HDR
repair pathway following this I will
step us through to virtual genome
engineering experiments and these will
specifically showcase the web design
tools built by our expert bioinformatic
cysts and software developers here at
dharmic on these virtual experiments
will include designing repair template
as a single stranded donor all ago and
also as a donor plasmid for a quick
introduction starting in 2012 the first
studies were published demonstrating the
Streptococcus pyogenes CRISPR catheline
systems can be adapted for use in human
and mouse cells since then there have
been thousands of publications utilizing
CRISPR cast nine in mammalian cells as
well as additive editing genomes from
other organisms the utility of CRISPR
cash 9 has revolutionized how quickly we
can knock out genes to address our
biological questions
all right so let's take a quick look at
the mechanism so that all of the
experimental components that we
discussed today will make sense in s
pyogenes the CRISPR RNAs are transcribed
and processed into short RNAs and with a
20 nucleotide spacer drive sequence and
a 22 nucleotide repeat drive sequence
separately a longer RNA called tracer is
also transcribed the crispr RNA and
tracer RNA hybridize and then recruit
the caste 9 nucleus which uses the
spacer drive sequence as a guide to its
DNA target the target sequence is
proximal to the 3 nucleotide proto
spacer adjacent motif or pan once all of
the components are in place the DNA is
cleaved by the catheline nucleus and can
be repaired by the cell's own repair
pathway which I'll talk about a little
bit more in a few slides to adapt this
system for gene editing in mammalian
cells there are two required CRISPR
casts nine components that need to be
introduced the cast 9 nucleus as well as
the guide RNA previously I mentioned the
crispr RNA tracer RNA hybrid as it is
the native system but this technique can
also be carried out using a chimeric
single guide RNA or FG RNA as shown here
on the right where the crispr RNA and
tracer RNA are linked into a single
piece single guide RNAs can either be
expressed from a vector or chemically
synthesized using synthetic single guide
RNA or CRISPR tracer RNA can have
several advantages over vector based
guide irony's including that they don't
require any cloning and sequencing and
are immediately ready to deliver into
your cells for gene knockout or knockin
experiments as I mentioned previously
when the Cassadine nucleus creates a
double strand break the cells own DNA
repair mechanisms kick in two of the
major pathways in mammalian cells for
such repair are non-homologous end
joining or nhej a and homology directed
repair or HDR nhej a may or may not
result in perfect repair often the site
of cleavage has mutations due to
insertions and deletions or endo for
short this is sufficient for functional
gene knockout experiments where the
desired outcome is an in del that
results in a frameshift mutation on the
other hand HDR is used for precise
genome engineering such as inserting a
point mutation or generating a knockin
it requires a donor DNA template for
repair of the double strand break HDR
typically has lower overall efficiency
compared to NH EJ but has the ability to
result in a precise genomic edit so for
HDR in addition to the cast nine and
guide RNA the donor or repair template
is also required for the remainder of
this talk we will focus on experiments
designed to utilize the HDR pathway here
are just a few of the ways researchers
are using HDR making alterations or
Corrections of diseased alleles
insertion or removal of a snip attaching
an affinity tag to a gene to study
protein interactions or to carry out
purifications
also you can knock in a fluorescent
reporter to visualize the location of
your protein or the localization of your
protein in your cell as well as changing
exons to study their effect on cellular
pathways or diseases depending on what
type of application you're doing there
are different reagents that should be
used as donors for precise repair in
general for small insertions deletions
or replacements single-stranded DNA
are used for larger knock ins plasma
donors are recommended because they are
more suited for larger payloads
currently more research is ongoing
looking at different sources of donor
templates today we will go over the
design of these two classic types of
repair consulates and we'll do this in
our virtual HDR genome engineering
experiments the two experiments that we
will walk through today are to introduce
a snip in our gene of interest using a
single stranded DNA algo as a donor
template and second we will design a
plasmid plasmid donor to knock in a
fluorescent reporter in frame with our
gene of interest the basic workflow
starts with choosing the appropriate
type of CRISPR reagents and then
designing guide RNAs to test for
functionality in the region of the HDR
insertion we will also need to design
the repair template this will be the
main focus of the rest of the workshop
next we need to Co transfer Co transfect
our cast 9 guide RNA and repair template
into ourselves and then finally we will
detect and verify the intended genomic
alteration alright so let's start with
our first step which is to choose the
most appropriate CRISPR cash 9
components thermicon provides a wide
range of these reagents through our
editor product line we have Cassadine
nucleus available as protein mRNA
lentiviral particles and plasmids we
also have multiple formats of guide RNA
including synthetic crispr RNA and
tracer RNA synthetic single guide RNA
and lengthy viral particles and plasmids
that express the single guide RNA and
then for HDR repair templates we have
single stranded DNA donor
eligos for those smaller genomic
alterations and plasmid donor kits for
the larger insertions
and then we also have an option where
you can insert your own custom sequence
although all of these reagents are good
for other applications the end goal of
an HDR experiment is to make a clonal
cell line with a desired alteration
because of this for HDR specific
applications
we recommend using cast 9 protein or
mRNA with a synthetic guide RNA these
sources give high editing efficiencies
which is important because the HDR
repair will be a fraction of the total
repair additionally these reagents have
a quick turnover that can reduce
potential off-target effects from
persistent expressions of caste 9 or the
guide RNA after the desired not going to
curse and finally there will be no
integration of trans or transient
expression of caste 9 or guide RNA
components in your final altered clonal
cell lines
alright so an important step that goes
hand-in-hand with choosing CRISPR caste
9 reagents is optimizing their
transfection into your specific cell
line there are many factors that need to
be optimized for cellular transfection
including cell density caste 9 amount
guide RNA amount and then potentially
the transduction method if you're
choosing between different transfection
reagents or you might require
electroporation and you may already have
good delivery conditions for your cell
line that can be used as a starting
point but here is an example of
transfection optimization as we
recommend performing if you're starting
with a completely new cell type in this
chart we're looking at cell viability
using cap 9 mrna with a positive control
CRISPR tracer RNA targeting PPI B we
used arm effect duo transfection reagent
in you to OS cells DRAM effect duo is
formulated for code transfection env is
it all the time forecast line protein
and mRNA with synthetic guide RNA
alright so in addition to
the editing efficiency should also be
assessed when we're optimizing our
transactions to look at the PPID editing
a t71 mismatch detection assay was run
on all conditions to compare the
relative editing of the positive control
on the right I'm sharing a small subset
of the editing results from the lipid
amount of 0.3 microliters per well what
we can see is that although the
viability across these different CRISPR
tracer RNA amounts was equivalent we
actually see the best editing with a 25
nano molar amount
the trick to transfection optimization
is finding a balance between viability
and editing often the highest liability
also shows low editing in our experience
somewhere around 80% viability generally
it gives good editing efficiency while
maintaining healthy cells ok now that we
have the transfection conditions in our
cell type that give efficient editing
with a positive control we can design
our guide RNAs and then just so we're
clear the guide RNA design steps are the
same for both the experiments than
demonstrating today so I will only go
through these steps once in a moment
I'll show you how this is all done with
a dharmic on CRISPR design tool but
first I will walk us through all the
steps that you would need to have to
carry out if you didn't have our design
tool to do it for you
first you would need to obtain the
genomic DNA sequence and determine the
location for your specific alteration
next you need to identify the Pam's in
that genomic region in close proximity
to the insertion or alteration site
ideally we want the guide RNA cut site
to be within 10 base pairs of insertion
typically the closer they are the better
hgr efficiency is observed
now in some genomic locations there
won't be a pam site near the cut site so
in those cases we will have to choose
the nearest available
Asians and anticipate having lower
efficiency which means characterizing
more clonal cell lines in your
downstream applications this
illustration indicates the availability
of three Pam's therefore three potential
guide RNA target sites are near our
alteration site with these three guide
RNAs and minds will next check for
specificity to reduce the possibility of
cleaving at another genomic location for
this we need to use a sequence alignment
tool that will look for full or partial
alignment against the whole genome and
then just as a reminder the rigor of the
publicly available tools will vary quite
a bit so it's possible that we might
miss some genomic off targets that only
have partial complementarity then we
need to test these available guide RNA
for functionalities for that we go back
to our optimized transfection conditions
and run a mismatch detection assay to
find the guide RNA with the best editing
efficiency finally we choose the most
functional and specific guide RNA that's
nearest to our alteration site in this
illustration we would select guide RNA
number two because it gave us the best
editing efficiency and presumably
acceptable specificity and then it also
has the added benefit of the cut site
being very close to our desired
alteration alright so the workflow that
we just walk through can be
time-consuming and even confusing if
you're new to this sort of experimental
design let me now show you how easy it
is with our CRISPR design tool for guide
RNA so now I'm going to move away from
my slides and show a live demonstration
just give me a second to set up my
desktop share
there we go all right so at our website
for and we're going to choose the CRISPR
design tool and the CRISPR design tool
is a wizard type tool that will walk us
through all the steps to design our
guide RNAs and and then we can order
either our synthetic single guide RNAs
or synthetic CRISPR RNAs or lentiviral
single guide RNA so in the beginning
here we have to choose our design
options and so there are four different
choices the first one is to input your
gene ID your gene symbol to design
anywhere within your gene excuse me um
the second one is to input and so the
first the first option is typically used
for knockout experiments and then the
second one input your gene ID or gene
symbol specific cleavage location for
HDR is the tool is the pathway that I'm
going to lead us through today and then
there's a third option where we can
provide a DNA region for design and our
tool can design to up to 30 species or
more than 30 species actually and so if
you're working with something that's uh
Nana cated that isn't part of those 30
species this is where someone might just
insert that region for designs only in
that area and then the fourth option is
to input your own guide RNA sequence
alright so we'll just keep going here
so the next step is to specify your
organism and you can see here this
drop-down box comes up with all the
organisms that we can choose between if
you start typing in the organism you
want to work with then you can select it
from the box the drop-down box and we
can do the same thing for our gene
target and then for today's
demonstrations I'm going to use the gene
CD kn1 a and then select that from the
drop-down list again
all right and so then with this
experiment since I am doing one design
for both both of our virtual experiments
I'm going to go ahead and click this
check box and it's only required for if
you're using HDR donors but since I'm
doing both I'm going to go ahead and
click it and proceed alright so now we
have this nice visualization of our of
our genes and above here we have introns
and green exons in blue and then the
dark blue is the coding regions and we
can you see this red selection window we
can click on the transcript above and
then below we can see a more detailed
view of of the transcript we can also
zoom in or zoom out in this above view
but once we find the location that we
want our genomic alteration then we go
down to this view below and we will
click in the location that we want to
change now for the two examples that
were going through today one of them is
we're just going to introduce a snip and
and so I'll walk us through that first
and the other one will be the
fluorescent insertion and so we want
this to be an n-terminal fluorescent
insertion so I'm going to pick guide
RNAs that are near this end terminal but
in the first example we'll do a snip so
in my first example I want to change
this T to something else so I'm going to
click right here alright so here we have
all of the guide RNA designs populated
close to our insertion or alteration
site that we've chosen and we're
providing a lot of information in this
view so
I can just walk us through the legend
pretty quickly before we before we go
ahead and choose and so the guide RNAs
look like an arrow and at the tail of
the arrow we have our specificity
ranking and the specificity ranking will
either be visualized as high medium or
low and it uses our makan alignment tool
and this alignment tool gives fully
comprehensive specificity checking and
so we can be confident that we're not
hitting anywhere else in the genome and
in all of the results that we have here
everything is high and so that doesn't
even have to be a factor in our choices
for this example and then the other side
of the arrow we have a functionality
rank and those rankings are numbered and
number one is the highest rank and the
way that we come up with this
functionality rank is based on the
editor functionality algorithm balanced
with the distance from the crisper cut
site to our alteration sites and so this
is really based on you know where
specifically you want your alteration to
be and these are the best functional
guide rnas in that location and so so
then because we have high specificity
and we want to balance that with our
functionality we can go ahead and choose
our top three rated functionality guide
RNAs so then I'll do that and I'll go to
the next screen and then here we have it
in a table format where we can see our
we can see our designs and I'm just
going to go ahead and copy and copy this
one for later on in the demo but and
then at this point we can choose our
format so we can choose crispr RNA
lentiviral single guide RNA where we
could have either glycerol
or high titer Lenti viral particles or
our synthetic single guide RNA which
comes in a one animal amount so for this
example we'll go ahead and just use
CRISPR tracer RNA and here we can choose
between two and twenty and animal size
for the three CRISPR RNAs that we're
going to order and add those to our
cards and then I can scroll down a
little bit and and remember to choose if
you if we don't already have synthetic
tracer that's required with the CRISPR
we can go ahead and order that as well
and in this case we can order larger
amounts because this is the universal
component then go ahead and add that to
our cart too and then I guess I should
mention that there's this plate format
option and so that is if you have more
than twenty 20 or more crispr RNA
designs you can order it in a plate
format and and it will come delivered to
you it in a 96-well plate format so you
would just choose that here and so then
we can just go to our cart and checkout
and we're done
so now I'm going to end the screen
sharing and get back to them all right
okay so now that we've designed our
guide RNAs let's move on to the next
step in our virtual experiment where we
will introduce our snip as a quick recap
for this experiment we will use test 9
mRNA the synthetic two-part guide RNA
and a single strand DNA repair template
to serve as our donor for HDR now we're
ready to design our repair template
again I will walk us through all the
steps of doing the design and then I
will demonstrate using the dharmic on
HDR donor designer to carry this out
more easily so for the first step we go
back to the genomic DNA sequence
surrounding the gene alteration site we
capture this sequence including homology
sequence on either end and incorporate
the desired alteration in this
illustration I'm showing our introduced
snip in blue changing one base to an A
for DNA a logo donors we need to
consider the sequence space for homology
arms here on the right I'm showing you
the results from an experiment that we
performed on two different genes to
determine the optimal homology arm
lengths from these data we concluded
that 30 to 40 nucleotides of homology on
either end are sufficient for optimal
incorporation by HDR next we should
double check for any errors in design
for instance if your donor adds a base
but doesn't also remove a base you will
end up with a frameshift mutation and
introduce a premature stop codon as
shown here on the right when what we
really wanted to do was just modify one
codon finally it is important to make
sure that cache line doesn't continue to
cut the hgr repaired DNA this is
possible if the guide RNA recognition
site and the Pam are within one of the
homology arms like in this example shown
luckily there are strategies to prevent
this the easiest way to avoid this is if
the change we are making naturally
disrupts the guide RNA targeting site in
this case where the guide RNA is
indicated by the gray shaded area we're
showing an insertion of 12 bases which
falls within the guide RNA targeting
sequence so the guide RNA had no longer
has complementarity when the guide RNA
targeting site will still be intact
after the alteration occurs one or more
silent mutations are required to avoid
continued cutting of the desired product
and then because the cache line protein
first recognizes the pam sequence before
looking for additional complementarity
it's recommended to first attempt to
make the silent mutation to change the
pam in this example we modify the donor
all ago to change the Pam from CGG to
CGC
so the arginine amino acid is preserved
but the Pam is not recognizable finally
if the Pam site is not available for a
silent mutation then the next proximal
codon should be changed and so on
throughout the guide RNA we also
recommend two silent mutations if the
pan and the seed region of the guide RNA
cannot be changed this example changes
GTG to GGA preserving the glycine amino
acid but disrupting the first nucleotide
of the seed okay that might've seemed
like a lot of information but now that
I've introduced all the design
considerations for donor oligos let me
show you how easy this is to do with our
HDR donor designer with another live
demonstration here so I will get my
desktop share going again so here we are
at our HDR donor designer and we're
going to choose the Ala go options
alright so then this is similar to the
design tool where we can just enter our
species from a drop-down list and then
choose it from below the same thing with
our gene targets CD kn1 a alright and
then we can choose a different
transcript if if wanted but the default
is always the primary transcript we'll
just continue with that and then here
I'm going to paste in that guide RNA
that we selected in the previous
demonstration and we're pretending that
this one is the one that was the best
when we tested it on our own out of
those three we picked this one as our
our big winner alright and so then now
we have a visualization again of the
genomic regions surrounding our guide
RNA and then we have this
slider bar where we can change our
insertion or alteration locations and so
in this example we want to change this T
to an a so we'll type in an a here in
this in this space for sequence to
insert and then we can change the length
of our 5 prime or 3 Prime homology arm
can go ahead and click generate DNA
donor and I'll scroll down a little bit
alright and so what we can see here is
maybe one of those common errors that
someone could make where they're
introducing an A but but here I forgot
to remove the T so now I don't have a
silent mutation I have a fringe
frameshift mutation and it's indicated
here in the design tool so it'll stop us
from making that mistake and so what we
do is unlock this slider bar and then we
can position the slider bar to surround
the DNA that we want to remove and once
we do that then it shows up here in the
field below and so now we have our donor
sequence and it's down here we're going
to select it so we can order it and we
can see our point mutation where we're
changing our searing amino acid to a
threonine amino acid in this in this
example and in the parenthesis here 61
is the length of this donor sequence so
we can go through and you know pretend
to check out with this one so we'll give
it a unique a unique name so CD KN one a
donor one
and here we can select our scale 0.5 or
1 micromolar scale so this is synthesis
scale and so the final yield just
depends on the length of your ala go and
then you can choose to have HPLC
purification or not and we have shown
that the purification isn't isn't
required and then the next option here
is to include stabilizing modifications
and then this is something that we do
recommend to improve HDR functionality
and it consists of two fossil evaluate
linkages that are on either end of the
donor hologram then we can just add to
our cart and that's the end well nope
actually let me show you one more
example where I'm going to get back to
our CRISPR designs from the last one and
choose a different design so I can show
you how we can easily introduce those
silent mutations and now we'll say
display target region again and so now
you can see that this guy dining is
shifted away from our desired alteration
site so if we set this up again to
change our T to an a to correct our snip
we now have many more alternative donor
sequences and a recommended donor
sequence that has this blue highlighted
area here where we've introduced the
snip and and the way that we do this is
how we've recommended it and how I just
talked about it before where we're going
to introduce a silent mutation in the
pan and then walk down the guide RNA
through the seed and then we'd have two
mismatches two snips after that region
but really they're if unless there is a
reason that you wouldn't want the
recommended donor sequence
because that specific snip is
unacceptable for your application you
should always go ahead and choose the
recommended donor sequence alright so
now we're done with this part of the
demo and up to our slides alright so now
that we have all the components that we
need to generate our precision edited
cell line we're ready to go ahead and do
our code transfection because we've
already optimized our conditions for
delivery with our calf line mrna and our
CRISPR tracer RNA and now all we have to
do is add in the donor all ago and
figure out what that optimal
concentration should be and so on the
right is an example of this type of
experiment using cells with stabilux
cast line expression and the olive akan
sensations that we used ranged up to 100
nano molar and this is shown on the
x-axis and the total HDR percent is
reported on the y-axis and then as you
can see the donor the DNA donor all ago
concentrations ranging between 2.5 and
10 nano molar give the most efficient
HDR integration so this is our ongoing
recommendation for DNA algo
concentration that you'll find in all of
our protocols for lipid transactions
after the CRISPR and HG are done donor
components have been delivered in our
code transfection
will then need to perform clonal cell
isolation and colony expansions and this
is how you get a homogenous population
that you can then characterize for your
desired alteration in this case a snip
change depending on the expected HDI
percentage the appropriate number of
clones should be expanded and then
Sanger sequenced with primers flanking
the desired genomic alteration here in
this example of Sanger sequencing we're
showing a homozygous correction of a
snip now it's not usually that
and so I wanted to show an example from
another experiment where it's showing
examples of the varied sequencing
results that we often get from clonal
cell lines in this case we inserted an
NH e 1 restriction site with a 1 X flag
tag at the c-terminal end of the e MX 1
gene
keep in mind that the maximum HDI
percentage will be less than the
original percent editing by the caste 9
and guide RNA alone and that during the
process of clonal isolation clones will
drop out for many reasons such as more
than one cell per well your single cells
are not growing or the desired
alteration is only present in a subset
of alleles or there are other mutations
in addition to the desired alteration so
it's recommended to carry several clonal
cell lines through two Sanger sequencing
here we see three different outcomes in
the Sanger sequencing analysis the first
one is the wild-type or no insertion at
all the second one is the heterozygous
example of evident with evidence of the
insertion on at least one allele but the
other allele or alleles have different
mutations and then the third example is
the actual desired homozygous clone
where all the alleles contain the
insertion all right so that brings us to
the end of our first virtual experiment
we covered a lot so just a quick recap
of what we've done so far was optimizing
our transfection conditions using and
then using our CRISPR design tool for
guide RNAs specific for HDR using the
donor designer to order a single
stranded DNA donor all ago then we
transfected everything together in our
HDR experiment and finished up with the
clonal isolation and Sanger sequencing
to confirm our correction and then on
the right I've listed the recommended
conditions to start with that we also
have listed in all of our manuals
protocols alright so now we can talk
about the second virtual experiment
where we will use a plasmid repair
template to create a fluorescent gene
fusion for this experiment we will
demonstrate using Cassadine protein the
synthetic two-part guide RNA and the mk2
plasmid repair template I'm not going to
repeat any of the steps for the guide
RNA design or transduction optimization
because those steps again are the same
regardless of the type of repair
template being used so we're going to
jump right into the design and then
assemble our plasmid donor for Phillip
for fluorescent knockin alright so as
with the donor I'll ago I will again
walk us through all the steps of design
as if we're doing it on our own and then
I'll show you how simple it is to do
this with our donor designer first we
need to obtain the genomic DNA sequence
in this example case we want to add mk2
to the c-terminus of cdk
and 1a the guide RNAs that we chose
remember though I were designed to the
n-terminal as an n-terminal alteration
but I thought I would walk us through
kind of both both ends for this design
process alright so then the next thing
that we have to do with our genomic DNA
is make sure that we have additional
genomic sequence on either end so we
need to retrieve enough genomic sequence
so that we can have our desired homology
arm lengths and from recent publications
and what we recommend this should be
between 500 and a thousand base pairs
alright so now we need to design our PCR
primers to amplify the desired homology
arms from the cell type that will be
used the small diagram at the top right
of this slide shows a schematic of how
the primers need to be designed and this
is shown by both sets of the blue arrows
and then for plasmid assembly we need to
append adapter sequences to the primers
as well and these are shown by the red
tails and the yellow tails following
those blue arrows I will take us through
step by step first we choose our insert
adjacent primers are those that are
complementary to the DNA immediately
adjacent to the site of the mk2
insertion and these are shown on the
larger diagram with the green arrows
here next we choose the gene based
portion of the corresponding primer pair
and in that case there can be multiple
options depending on the desired
homology arm length and the PCR
conditions this is because there's
plenty of sequence base both five-prime
and three-prime of the insertion site in
this example the 5-prime homology arm
amplicon will be 865 basis and the 3.3
prime amplicon will be 552 now that we
have the gene specific parts of our
primer pairs determined we have to
append the adapters that are specific to
the donor for each of the primers here
are the five prime homology arm primers
and here are the three prime Amala g arm
primers with those adapters included now
this step can be tricky because it's
easy to make a manual error when you're
appending the adapter sequence and even
getting them in the correct orientation
alright and so then again the last step
like i presented earlier is to check and
modify the primers if needed to include
silent mutations to avoid this ongoing
cleavage of the corrected DNA and this
is very similar to the guidelines I
presented earlier but the main
difference is that the silent mutations
need to be incorporated into primers and
not simply the donor all ago so first
again and easiest is the case where the
certian naturally disrupts the guide RNA
targeting site shown in gray in this
case no modification needs to be made to
the primer designs because the mk2 will
be inserted in the middle of the guide
RNA targeting site
alternatively and as we discussed
earlier when the guide RNA targeting
site will still be intact after the
insertion one or more silent mutations
are required to avoid this continued
cutting of the desired product so here
we again recommend to first attempt to
make a silent mutation to the Pam in
this example we're using the primer
design to change the Pam from a dg2 a ga
so the arginine amino acid is preserved
but the Pam is no longer recognizable
and then again if the Pam site is unable
to be changed and then the next proximal
codon should be changed and so on
throughout the guide RNA and again we
recommend you know two silent mutations
if the Pam and the seed cannot be
changed in this example we're changing
CTA to CTC preserving the leucine amino
acid but disrupting the first nucleotide
of the seed and then again this is the
same as I discussed before but the
silent mutations are introduced with the
primers with mismatches alright so here
we go now that we've seen all the design
considerations and that is even more
complicated for plasmids let me show you
how easy this is to do with our donor
designer for plasmids and alright so now
in this case we are going to choose the
donor designer for plasmids and then
this is very similar to the awl ago tool
we're going to select human again from
the drop-down our gene target
and we're going to keep with the primary
transcript and now here are sequence to
insert we can choose from either mk2
egfp or this custom insert and then I'll
just show you how the custom insert
works where all you have to do is copy
and paste your sequence that's more than
50 nucleotides into this text box and
and then that'll be used for the primer
design one of the things I should say is
that it is if you're working with
anything that's 50 nucleotides are or
less or just a little bit over 50
nucleotides and it's best to go ahead
and use The Awl ago design tool because
it's a lot less work and then the other
thing that I need to mention is that the
sequence that you enter here needs to be
something that you have yourself it's
not something that we would synthesize
synthesize and provide so that is not
included in our kit and so here I'll
just go back to the mk2 sequence to
insert and I will paste in our guide RNA
target sequence alright so then the view
here is very similar to what we saw
before where we have our introns and our
X X and our start of our coding region
here and so what we do is we move our
slider bar in this case it's indicating
what we're inserting which is mk2
we move it to the location that we want
and then we go ahead and generate
primers alright so here we are with our
primers so here we have to choose now
are our pairs for our v prime homology
arms and our three prime homology arm
primer pairs and like I said before the
insert adjacent primer
are are fixed and so there aren't you
know other options for those and so you
can see here this sequence ends with
this ATG and so it's the sequence here
and then the insert the forward to
primer starts with the sequence here but
then in blue we can see that that is the
silent mutation that was automatically
incorporated into the design because in
this case our guide RNA would not be
disrupted by the insertion of mk2
because it's fully intact in the 3-prime
homology arm here so we would go ahead
and choose choose those two and then we
need to choose our distal primers and
and so typically you want to choose the
top one because these are ranked based
on based on PCR quality scores from
primer 3 and so I would go ahead and
pick the top one but what you can do is
look over here on on the right where we
have our TMS and the links and so these
are the length of the homology arms so
you can you can see that but if for some
reason you wanted a longer homology arm
you could choose you could choose a
different one and in some cases you
might want to choose a couple a couple
different primer pairs to start out with
so that you have backup options if if
you're having trouble with the PCR but
in this case we'll just choose the two
pairs and then what we need to do is
make sure that we have our donor kit
included and then of course if if you're
coming back to order new primers and you
already have the kit you can deselect
this at that point and then we can go
ahead and give it a unique name again so
I guess I would call this primer set
primer set one and then I could go ahead
and add to my cart so that's how easy
this is I'll get back to the
presentation shop and actually build our
donors okay so now that we've designed
and ordered our custom homology iron
primers and the HDR donor kit we're
ready to build the donor plasmid the
first step is to PCR amplify the
homology arms from ourselves genomic DNA
and gel purified the expected product we
then need to remember that the
full-length product will include the
full length homology arm as well as the
adapters so there's going to be at about
50 nucleotides addition to those
homology links when you're analyzing it
on the gel alright so next we'll combine
all those components both homology arms
the mk2
insert and the backbone for a four
fragment Gibson assembly both the vector
backbone and the insert will arrive as
part of the HDR plasmid donor kit but
the kit doesn't provide the Gibson
assembly reagents so at that point then
we'll transform it into bacteria and the
next day perform our colony PCR with the
primers that are also included in that
HDR donor kit this gel on the Left shows
the colony PCR analysis for 10 clones
where a is the five prime arm and B is
the three prime arm as you can see all
the two of the clones indicate the
expected size has been inserted for both
arms next finger sequence a few of the
clones that appear positive to confirm
the correct assembly and then the final
step is to prep the confirmed plasmid
for transfection so then as a quick
recap on the kits to create donor
plasmids the HDR donor kit contains the
custom and catalog items you need to
amplify your
mala ji arms assemble nqc your donor
plasmid each kit contains enough to do
10 reactions so you would only need to
do the design of your primers and then
you can purchase purchase those
separately but you could do you know ten
different napkins with one of the donor
kits all right so then similar to our
logo transfection we now can do our real
HDR experiment where we transfect
everything together
but we need to include our plasmid and
optimize our delivery conditions
including that plasmid so in this
example I'm showing the results from a
slightly different knockin experiment
than the virtual one we just did so bear
with me here we did a delivery by
electroporation in k562 cells with the
plasma donor to create an egfp fusion
with the laminae gene on the left you
can see an increase in egfp expression
as the amount of donor plasmid is
increased and then on the right you can
look at where we used fax to quantify
the percentage of egfp positive cells
and we can observe an HDR rate as high
as 32% and then from this highest
population of egfp positive cells we can
go on to do clonal isolation and Sanger
sequencing to confirm the insert and
then grow up this new cell line for
future desired experiments laminae is a
structural protein in the nucleus and
although it's hard to visualize the
suspension cells it's evident a little
that the localization is in the nucleus
from applying Hookes staining and
merging the images as shown here and
then finally there are several more
examples of fluorescent knock ins that
we have generated with an HDR donor
plasmid with our synthetic guide rnas
and either cast nine nucleus mRNA or
protein on the Left we see a G
P beta-actin fusion where we can clearly
see actin filament structure next we see
a GFP HMG a fusion with a bright nuclear
localization and on the right we see
both GFP and mk2 661 B fusions with
distinct localization in the endoplasmic
reticulum so in the second virtual
experiment we focus mainly on the design
and assembly of the donor plasmid since
we covered all the other steps in
experiment 1 but what we accomplished
was using the donor designer to design
compatible primer pairs to easily
generate a donor plasmid utilizing our h
CR donor kit
next we transfected all the components
that were we transfected all the
components for these HDR experiments and
then i showed several examples of
successful gene fusions and then again
on the right i have listed the
experimental recommendations that can be
found in our technical manuals and
protocols for these types of experiments
so that was a lot to cover thanks for
sticking with me I think I managed to
cover everything you need to get started
with HDR mediated CRISPR cast nine
experiments including designing and
testing guide RNAs for HDR applications
designing an ordering appropriate repair
templates and detection and verification
of the desired HDR edit in a cell
population I've hopefully demonstrated
how intuitive and helpful
the dharmic on online tools are and they
can really help do a lot of heavy
lifting when it comes to guide RNA and
HDR donor design for eligos or plasmids
our team has worked really hard on these
to overcome a lot of the day-to-day
challenges of doing these designs
properly and helping to avoid common
errors we just hope that this is helpful
for you too and when you come to our
website and start playing around with
the design tools
please take a look at our growing
collection of resources including all
these application notes that ends
several of them have some of the
examples that I walked through today
with our HDR workflows and then you can
also find references to peer-reviewed
publications from our Rd team and
collaborators and lastly since you've
already shown interest in webinars be
sure to check out our collection of
other recorded webinars covering a
number of talk topics that we hope will
interest you as you plan your future
experiments and with that Louise I'm
done and ready to take any questions and
there are usually everyone for your
attention
yes thank you Maren that was so good
information we did use up a lot of our
time but we will give you a minute to
catch your breath we will do a few
questions while we get ready for that
there are two polling questions that
will appear on your screen we really
appreciate you answering these just
click the most appropriate response and
you can still submit questions by typing
them into that Q&A box just click on
that green Q&A button at the lower left
as I mentioned all the questions will be
answered via email that we don't get to
today all right Marion here we go just a
few of these here are the conditions you
mentioned for the amount of crispr RNA
all ago donor and Cassadine protein
going to be the same for all cell types
okay yeah good question the conditions
that I mentioned are a good starting
point and in our hands they've been
fairly similar for the handful of you
know immortalized cell lines that we use
all the time however I can't emphasize
enough how important optimization is so
if you're having trouble in your cell
line make sure that you start at the
beginning of this workflow that I
presented today and then optimize
everything for maximal HDR incorporation
awesome
next should I label the sea or the
n-terminus of my gene okay yeah let's
see my suggestion would be to just do a
few searches to see if any other groups
have already made and/or c-terminal
fusions of you know your the gene that
you are working with and if so I would
go ahead and start with those conditions
that previously worked if no one has
published this then you know you can go
ahead and try designs to both ends or
you could also get lucky and find you
know a crystal structure of the protein
and then maybe you could infer if one
end or the other would be more available
for tagging and then thinking of that I
should sorry Louise I should also
mention that our design includes
flexible amino acids on either end so
fusion proteins made with our designs
will not be a direct fusion and because
of this flexibility they'll be more
functional hopefully right so getting
the gradient get a point yeah okay so
one more you showed an example where a
frameshift that introduced could
introduce a premature stop codon might
this be a strategy for doing gene knock
out sure sure yeah that could definitely
be a strategy for gene knockout but keep
in mind the efficiency of repair
pathways if your goal is knockout but
you don't care how it would likely be
more efficient to rely on nhej a but if
you want to knock out your protein in a
very specific way then designing a
single strand DNA donor all ago that
will introduce a premature stop codon
would be you know a great strategy right
okay well we've gone a little bit over
so thank you again for the great
presentation thanks to the audience for
your questions and for your attention if
anyone thinks of more questions later
and needs to contact us please do just
visit our web
site you have information there where
you can call directly or email or chat
online with one of our tech support
scientists on behalf of the whole derma
con team we want to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible and the webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February you'll receive an email from
lab roots alerting you to when the
webcast is available for on-demand
so if you have any colleagues who missed
today's event that might be interested
we invite you to afford that email
announcement to them or just send them
to our website thanks again for joining
hope everyone has a great day